this week marks three big budgetary
issues for joe biden and he's got a
problem on every single one of them plus
biden continues to slander border patrol
i'm benchmark this is the bench bureau
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by
expressivevpn protect your data from
bigtech with vpni trust visit
expressvpn.com
slash ben well you may have noticed that
the biden administration continues to
want to blow out the budget now would be
an excellent time if you diversify at
least a little bit into something that
has never been worth zero i'm talking
about precious metals of course you can
see it at the pump the grocery store and
construction cost another month of the
highest inflation in what 15 years
another month where that paper money
you're carrying around is worth less so
what is your plan to protect your
savings you have homeowners insurance in
case of a fire what insurance do you
have in place if inflation sets in
further and pushes prices even higher my
insurance plan gold and silver for my
friends over at birch gold group if you
haven't reached out to birch gold to
diversify your ira or 401k into a
precious metals ira do it today text ben
247 4747 get a free information kit i'm
protecting your savings with gold they
have an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless five-star
views thousands of happy customers talk
to them have them help you safeguard
your retirement savings text ben to 47
47 47 to claim your free no obligation
information kid on holding gold and
silver in a tax sheltered account again
text my name ben to 47 47 47 take the
first step in protecting your savings
today again text my name ben 47 47 47 to
get started alrighty so joe biden is
facing down the possibility of a failed
presidency a fully failed presidency and
we are approximately nine months in to
his presidency at this point on every
front he faces crisis specifically this
week he faces a serious crisis on the
domestic front on the domestic financial
front this is the place where he was
supposed to excel he can't get his party
together and that is because he is not
governing the way that he said that he
would be governing
a lot of presidents come into office
thinking that their mandate is broader
than what their actual mandate is in
2004 for example george w bush won
re-election and he said well i'm now the
decider and i'm going to push social
security privatization it's actually a
good plan but social security
privatization was not what he had a
mandate for he tried to push it it
backfired and his presidency was
basically lame duck from the beginning
of 2005 and on well joe biden is another
president who is like this and he is
elected on the basis of being a moderate
of not being bernie sanders and now he's
trying to govern like bernie sanders in
every possible way apparently and it has
backfired on him in spectacular fashion
we're getting bernie sanders without all
of the evuncular charm of the grouchy
old man shouting at the moon now we just
have a grouchy old man mumbling into his
soup
so it really has not worked out well for
joe biden which relegated him over the
weekend to basically mumbling on about
what a tough hand he had been dealt at
the beginning of his presidency here was
joe biden over the weekend
take a look at what i inherited when i
came into office when i came into office
the state of affairs and where we were
we had four million people vaccinated we
had no plan we had i mean i could go
down the list
so uh you know
part of it is
dealing with the panoply of things that
landed on my plate i'm not complaining
it's just a reality
um you are complaining and also you're a
liar
so i said this right after the election
joe biden was the luckiest man ever to
inherit the presidency the reason for
this is because he didn't campaign he
wasn't alive he was campaigning against
the most unpopular politician in modern
american history he basically won the
presidency on the basis of being a dead
body and he was inheriting the end of a
pandemic vaccines that worked
an economy that had been going great
guns before the artificial coma of the
pandemic itself which was not caused
solely by the pandemic but largely by
government policy in response to the
pandemic a baseline of massive spending
had already been set up for him there's
no president who's inherited a situation
more likely to succeed than joe biden
we were a low ebb it was like when
barack obama took over and he could look
at the fact that we had a stagnant
economy and we had just faced this major
financial crisis and he could say that
anything that happened from here on him
was him and everything bad was his
predecessor joe biden basically had the
same ability he was going to get this
natural rebound in economic growth
everybody knew that it was going to
happen
a natural rebound that should have
lasted at least a couple of years joe
biden was going to get the benefit of
vaccines he did not develop and had
nothing to do with developing
he was going to get the benefit of a
foreign policy that not only had
produced no major wars over the course
of the last four years but also had
started producing actual peace
agreements in places like the middle
east
right what joe biden inherited was
actually one of the greatest hands any
president has ever inherited
he had inherited
problems that already had solutions to
them
and he
as always with his career he could jump
in front of the parade that was already
moving without him stand in front with
the baton and pretend that he was
leading the thing
he was really lucky but somehow he has
blown all of that and the reason he has
blown all of that is because he has
decided to pursue radical policy on
nearly every front and not just that
when you pursue radical policy and also
you are perceived as both incompetent
and senile that is never a good look
and by the way when i say he is
perceived as incompetent in senile
not by me
only i mean yes but also by apparently
the american public
a majority of americans now say that
president biden is not mentally sharp
according to a new poll from pew
research center
the survey which other which like other
polls shows biden's overall approval
rating sinking found that just 43 said
the phrase mentally sharp describes him
either very well or fairly well an
11-point drop from the same poll in
march 56 then said that the phrase
describes him well 56 now say the phrase
describes him as not at all well or not
too well
this was his worst showing in any of the
personal characteristics surveyed so
nearly six in ten americans say that he
is not mentally sharp
the other four in 10 americans are not
mentally sharp themselves apparently
because i'm i'm wondering what are the
symptoms of being mentally sharp if
you're joe biden
and all of this just underscored what
was going on with joe biden's crisis
underscores him personally
and this is what i say about the
difference between
a gaffe
and actual political crisis a gaffe is
where you say something stupid a
political crisis is where you say
something stupid and underscores your
entire political program
if you are
on the verge of being perceived as
senile and incompetent
and then you pursue a bunch of policy it
makes no sense it is just going to
underscore your personal characteristics
senile and incompetent and that's what's
happening with the american public right
now so this means that this week matters
an awful lot to joe biden this is
basically a make or break week for joe
biden in the financial sphere we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about a simple fact you are paying
too much for your cell phone coverage
stop paying for verizon a t and t mobile
social initiatives stop paying for their
thousands of retail stores across the
country and never go into stop paying
for the added perks you never use
instead just get what you need from your
cell phone provider i'm talking about
pure talk pure talk gives you killer 5g
coverage on the same 5g network as one
of the big guys for about half the cost
the average family is saving over 800 a
year so what's your excuse i made the
switch you can keep your number keep
your phone or get huge discounts on
latest iphones and androids get a
limited talk text six gigs of data for
just 30 bucks a month and listen if you
still want unlimited data you can get it
and still save a fortune head on over to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that's
right for you they have a 30 day risk
free guarantee so you literally have
nothing to lose head on over to
puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you will save 50 off your very first
month of coverage
that is puretalk.com use promo code
shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless why spend so that all of these
other companies can pay for their
overhead instead just buy what you need
from puretalk head on over to
puretalk.com promo code shapiro save 50
off your very first month and you'll be
saving hundreds of bucks down the road
okay so joe biden is now facing down a
bunch of fiscal issues all hitting at
the exact same time according to the
wall street journal
joe biden is headed into a tumultuous
week along with nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer a slew of high-stakes deadlines
will collide on capitol hill this week
setting up potentially chaotic
negotiations against a backdrop of
expiring government funding and the
threat of a possible us default even by
the standards of a capital used to
operating under pressure this week's
mail strum of legislative and fiscal
cross currents is setting the stage for
an extraordinary sprint democratic
leaders are trying to shepherd two
complicated legislative packages a
roughly one trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill and a sprawling
healthcare education climate package
whose proposed 3.5 trillion dollar price
tagging contents are still under intense
debate within the party so those are two
issues right you've got the bipartisan
infrastructure bill which is about a
trill and that is going to pass because
it has support in the senate of the
united states from some of the quote
unquote republican moderates but the
reason the republican moderates were
going to pass that is because they were
not pairing it with this 3.5 trillion
dollar bill the problem for the
democrats is that a bunch of
progressives in the house are saying
we're not going to support the
bipartisan infrastructure bill unless
you support the 3.5 trillion dollar bill
and a bunch of moderates in the senate
are like no we're not going to do that
we're going to support the bipartisan
infrastructure bill but not the 3.5 a
trillion dollar price tag so basically
you now have a prisoner's dilemma in
which the progressives and the moderates
inside the democratic party are at
whitten they are a standoff right now
the moderates want precisely the
opposite of what the progressives want
and there's not really a great way of
bridging that gap unless you have
serious presidential leadership which
you don't because joe biden is a vacuum
at the top of the united states
government which you know thank god for
that because the fact is
that if joe biden had any leadership
capacity at all he'd be cutting a deal
right now or at least pushing the
progressives but he is not because he is
an empty vessel who has decided that his
greatest legacy for the future is going
to be ramming through spending no matter
what it takes because he understands
that he is a one-term president
at the same time as both of those issues
which really ought not be paired have
been paired by joe biden and nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer right they're
pairing these two issues for no reason
other than the progressives want them
paired they don't have to be paired
the democrats could today pass that one
trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure package and nancy pelosi
could bring that up for a vote in the
house and it would pass it would because
presumably they'd get enough votes from
house republicans to put it over the top
even if the progressive democrats didn't
go along with it
the problem she has is that she also
wants to pass that giant 3.5 trillion
dollar bill
and the moderates in the senate don't
want to do that so she's trying to wrap
this all up in a ball and saying you
only get one if you get the other but
that's not going to work because
republicans are going to filibuster that
giant 3.5 trillion infrastructure
package forcing the democrats to use
reconciliation and joe manchin and
kristen cinema the so-called moderate
senators from west virginia and arizona
have said that they are not on board
with that she's trying to pair them on
behalf of the progressives when she
should be trying to separate them on
behalf of the moderates and they'll
solve all the problems because there is
a third problem which is that the
republicans are not willing to raise the
debt ceiling so long as democrats are
going to use reconciliation in order to
ram through the 3.5 trillion package
republicans are saying listen you want
to raise the debt ceiling fine do it you
have to pair it with your 3.5 trillion
package and see how that goes for you
see if mansion and cinema are willing to
go along with raising the debt ceiling
and the 3.5 trillion dollars and then
own it
democrats don't want to own it they want
republicans to vote along with them on
raising the debt ceiling republicans are
saying we're not going to do that unless
you jettison this 3.5 trillion dollar
plan
so you have this
basically the end of a of a quentin
tarantino film right it's reservoir dogs
everybody's just pointing their guns at
each other and it's just a question of
who fires first
at the same time as all this is
happening the government's funding is
set to expire 1201 am on friday october
1st that would partially shut down the
government if congress doesn't act
lawmakers are feuding over who's
responsible for raising the debt limit
and avoiding a potentially catastrophic
default absent swift action treasury
secretary janet yellen notified congress
this month treasury may be unable to
keep paying all of the government's
bills on time during october so first of
all whenever there's a government
shutdown for any period of time the
media will lose it and no one else does
because everybody who's an essential
worker gets their back pay there's no
chance that the government remains shut
down for an indefinite period of time
eventually the government always gets
funded
always and forever whether it is raising
taxes or whether it is or or whether it
is passing another bill like they are
going to do something to to get the
government funded and the government
will always be it's just a question of
the delay
and there the media always try to talk
up government shutdown as though people
are dying in the streets and zombie
apocalypse out there we've been through
several of these at this point and the
only thing that happened is that barack
obama last time around actively shut
down a national park that was in the
outdoors in the open air to piss off
world war ii veterans so we could
pretend that anyone cared about the
government shutdown in reality the
number of people who cared about the
government shutdown on a realistic level
was close to zero but the media care
deeply about it because it's how they
leverage everybody into just going ahead
with massive government spending and
that blows out the deficit
house speaker nancy pelosi said quote
this the next few days
will be a time of intensity
which is always a frightening line from
nancy pelosi the week could also test
the leadership of president biden
according to the wall street journal
who's been battered with criticism over
his handling of the afghanistan
withdrawal we'll get to that in a second
and the recent surge of haitian
immigrants at the southern border we
will also get to that in one moment
because biden is facing crisis on pretty
much every front i mean literally every
front like in afghanistan
on the southern border and domestically
the senate is expecting to vote monday
evening on a measure extending the
government's funding through december
3rd 2021 and suspending the debt limit
into december 2022 it's expected to be
blocked by democrat by republicans
leaving the matter unresolved democratic
leaders have not spelled out what their
next step will be but pelosi reiterated
sunday the government would not go into
partial shutdown she said democratic
leaders are preparing to bring up a
short-term spending patch which has
bipartisan support to avoid that outcome
so republicans are saying fine you know
we're not going to raise the
the debt limit but what we are going to
do
is fund it for the next couple of weeks
we'll fund it for the next couple of
weeks because then it's up to you
right we've given you the time to go
work this out on your own but we are not
going to green light a massive increase
in the debt ceiling democrats are like
well the debt ceiling is paying for
bills we have already incurred yes but
you are now asking for taking out a
second credit card and republicans are
just saying no to that until you get
your spending under control
it is true that we have to pay off the
debt that we have already incurred
but why would i keep extending you a
line of credit if you are just going to
blow out the credit continuously without
getting your house in order there should
be strings attached representative
debbie dingle democrat of michigan said
we're going to shut the government down
in the middle of a pandemic it's the
most irresponsible action that anyone
can really i can think of some more
irresponsible action than that namely
blowing out the budget to the tune of
seven trillion dollars this year i could
imagine that would be pretty
irresponsible considering we are now
facing severe inflationary pressure as
well as economic stagnation on the other
end
as the wall street journal points out
averting a partial government shutdown
this weekend would resolve only one of
the handful of complex legislative
battles a partisan fight over raising
the debt limit has started to infuse
anxiety into financial markets
republicans are refusing to vote for a
suspension or increase in the debt
ceiling pointing to democrats decisions
to pass a 1.9 trillion covet 19 relief
bill with no gop support earlier this
year and current efforts to pass that
3.5 trillion dollar package of social
and climate programs along party lines
senator patoumi who is a fiscal
conservative he is the republican from
pennsylvania he sits on the senate's
budget and finance committees he said he
might very well vote for a clean
continuation of funding that the
government will continue running but he
said there will be no attempt to raise
the debt ceiling by republicans he said
they are in the midst of an absolutely
unprecedented very damaging spending
spree on a scale we've never seen they
want us to come along and authorize the
borrowing to help pay for it when we are
totally opposed to what they are doing
so the the democrats are trying to blame
this on the republicans but since they
are in complete control of congress
that's going to be a tough push we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the clothes you'll wear
so i only wear one type of t-shirt i'm
talking about cuts clothing cuts it's
super comfortable it fits you great it
really looks good i'm telling you cuts
clothing is the tops it really is
fantastic if you strive for excellence
in every aspect of your life you need to
check out cuts of clothing cuts shirts
polos hoodies crew sweatshirts they're
made for the man who works hard plays
hard never settles for less all in the
sport of business built for performance
in the boardroom the bar or the gym cuts
clothing keeps you sharp wherever the
game takes you take a plain tee make it
tony stark the bleeding edge of fabric
technology meets the man confident
enough to wear cuts clothing cuts it out
to create a fabric uniquely engineered
for each clothing style so for example
they've got the new cut hoodie they
developed the hyperloop french carry
fabric it's a textile that's temperature
controlled and ageless you don't need to
take it off and you won't want to or you
can try the wrinkle-free picapolo a
design that keeps you fitted for the
office the golf course at home the gym
or your next hot date
again i pretty much only wear cuts
clothing at this point it is just that
good it's not just the lifestyle it's
not just clothing it's office leisure
apparel for the sport of business get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com that's
cutsclothing.com for 15 off the only
shirt worth wearing okay so the
democrats are facing down all of this at
the same time by the way that transitory
inflation seems to be lasting quite a
while remember that time they kept
talking about transitory inflation oh
it's transitory it's going away it's
transitory inflation well it's not
transitory inflation it's pretty severe
systemic inflation and the federal
reserve is worried about it enough that
now they're talking about tapering
they're talking about raising the
interest rates which by the way is the
only thing that solidified markets last
week in the middle of all of this the
markets are looking for some sign of
fiscal responsibility from either the
federal reserve or congress congress has
spent the last 20 years basically
forcing the federal reserve to do all
fiscal policy if they wanted stimulus
they just had the federal reserve do it
through quantitative easing if they
wanted the markets to tighten up they
forced the federal reserve to do it the
federal reserve became essentially the
financial king maker in american
politics
well now the federal reserve is saying
okay well i'm noticing that people are a
little skittish and we are going to have
to taper a little bit that is because of
inflationary pressures by the way
inflation is the way that you debase a
currency
inflation is the way that you debase
people's savings it's a way that you
steal political power from people and
bring it towards centralized government
okay that is agreed upon by people from
right to left everybody from frederick
hayek to john maynard keynes was well
aware that inflation was the way that
you destroy an economy
and that is precisely what the federal
reserve is afraid of right now as well
meanwhile joe biden's like okay fine
well if you if you're you guys are going
to taper i'm just going to spend i'm
just going to spend according to the
wall street journal all year the federal
reserve's message on inflation has been
consistent this year's surge its
transitory inflation will soon return
close to the central bank's two percent
target
now first of all i'm very much against
the idea that the central bank should be
setting a two percent target on
inflation why because what that means
that over the course of 20 years your
savings are worth 40 less
i know that we're never supposed to look
over the course of 20 years because as
mccain said in the long run we're all
dead but that's not even the long run
that's the medium run
right if if the federal reserve keeps
inflating the currency at two percent a
year over the course of 10 years
your money in the bank is worth 20 less
than it was when you started
it is a way to force you to spend right
that is what it is
it is a way to force you to invest you
like savings are bad according to the
federal reserve
now i'm not in favor of the notion that
the federal reserve should be setting a
standard of inflation by the way i don't
think the federal reserve should have
been tasked with full employment as
their goal since when is the job of a
regulatory agency full employment
should be the job of the congress to
ensure employment if that is what they
care about although employment is a
byproduct of a healthy economy it's not
the goal of a healthy economy
in any case the the wall street journal
says
if you look more closely it's clear
officials are turning less sanguine
about inflation that explains a growing
eagerness to raise interest rates last
september long before supply bottlenecks
emerged the median forecast by fed
officials was for core inflation
excluding food and energy in 2022 of 1.8
every few months since then they've
nudged that up in the forecast released
wednesday they see core inflation next
year at 2.3 percent
while current year forecasts get pushed
around by a lot of temporary factors
like a jump in oil prices the next year
forecasts reflect where inflation is
expected to settle once those temporary
factors recede the message from the
fed's latest projections is that
transitory is lasting an awfully long
time indeed next year's projected 2.3 is
the highest next year core inflation
forecast since the projections were
first published in 2007 according to
derek tang of monetary policy analytics
which is why the fed is accelerating
plans to raise the interest rates the
fed is currently buying 120 billion
dollars a month in bonds and wants that
to start to fall to zero before it
starts to raise rates on wednesday the
fed signaled it would be likely to start
tapering at bond purchases in november
that means the process would be over by
mid-2022 clearing the way for a rate
increase now as i've said inflation is
actually not my core worry here my core
worry is that when you regulate business
when you tell business that the
government is going to run it when you
say that the entire american economy
should run on principles of equity set
by the central bank and the government
of the united states what you are going
to do is cause stagnation you're going
to get secular stagnation japanese style
from the 1990s
which is by the way joe biden agrees
with that which is why he is forecast
that over the next 10 years the american
economy is going to grow like 1.5 1.6
those are terrible numbers those are
very bad numbers they don't even outpace
inflation
you talk about increase in wage numbers
solely due to inflation but real wages
are not going to increase if the
economic growth doesn't outpace
inflation
okay but joe biden is confident that
he's going to spend and he's going to
lie to you about all of this stuff what
democrats really don't want to talk
about at this point is who's going to
pay for this and what are the actual
goals of this policy other than to make
the american people more dependent on
government
other than to get the american people
into a warm bath and hook them up to an
iv and wait for them to bloat themselves
to death
so joe biden is just lying now right he
went out over the weekend he says you
know this 3.5 trillion dollar package
people people keep saying that's
expensive well actually the cost is zero
okay used car salesman explained to me
how 3.5 trillion spending package from
the government which makes no money the
government is not an independent
producer of money
the government of the united states can
only make money by selling bonds that
eventually have to be paid for by tax
dollars or by taxing you directly that
is the only way the federal government
is not a money-making entity it is
amending printing entity that is not the
same thing
joe biden says however don't worry this
3.5 trillion dollar package it costs
actually it costs zero
we talk about price tags
the it is
zero
price tag on the debt we're paying we're
going to pay for everything we spend
so they say it's not you know people
understandably
well you know it started off at 6
trillion now it's 3.5 trillion now it's
going to be 2.9
it's going to be zero
zero because in the in that plan
that i put forward and i said from the
outset
i said i'm running to change the dynamic
of how the economy grows
okay um
that's crazy so the cost is zero the
cost is zero because he says he's gonna
pay for okay number one he's not
he's lying because all of his baseline
budgeting for spending goes out over 15
years and all the tax revenue he's
talking about is raised over the course
of longer than that
it's like a 10-year budget it's the
reverse it's like a 10-year budget and
it's like a 15-year tax revenue scheme
and beyond that he is forecasting tax
revenue that is unlikely to occur
because of his economic policy finally
even if he were not lying even if his
actual plan encompassed the taxation to
cover the plan that doesn't make the
cost zero that makes the cost precisely
what the cost is
if i go down to the local grocery store
and i buy a gallon of milk
for
five bucks
that cost me five bucks just because i
paid for it doesn't mean that it was the
cost was zero in what insane world is
the cost zero when i pay for a thing
what in the world is he talking about
the answer is he's lying because they
have to lie to you because if they don't
lie to you you might say wait a second
we're spending money on what now what
are you talking about
we'll get some more of this in just a
second first let's talk about the fact
that your sleep quality should not be
compromised okay so i flew yesterday got
in real light went to kids put in bed
late finally got on that mattress
finally when i was ready to settle down
i needed to be on my helix sleep
mattress because it was made just for me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody's unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot mattresses great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you're
matched to the mattress comes directly
to your door shipped for free you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again they have a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights at risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will helix
even has financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away we love our helix
sleep mattress you will too why wouldn't
you it's made just for you head on over
to helixsleep.com take their two minutes
leave quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
check them out right now so this is joe
biden's pitch is that his agenda is free
okay literally he says this he tweeted
out today
my bill blackbutter agenda cost zero
dollars zero instead of wasting money on
tax breaks loopholes
tax evasions for late corporations and
wealthy
we can make a once in a generation
investment in working america and it
adds zero dollars to the national debt
okay that's just a lie it's just a lie
it's gonna add zero dollars to the
national debt he's setting in place
programs that are gonna have to be paid
for not
annually
not triannually perennially
these programs are permanent this is
what democrats do they set up programs
that are supposedly going to sunset five
ten years from now they never sunset
they only grow these programs are going
to be permanent entitlements in american
life joe biden knows this democrats know
this the notion that we're paying for
this stuff is absolute utter horse crap
it is not true
the build back better agenda costs zero
dollars by the way i love how he
characterizes this when he says instead
of wasting money on tax breaks
okay a tax break is not wasting
it's not your money
it's not your it's not your money okay
that that is like saying
that if i pay back the credit card
company that i'm wasting money
i'm not no it's not my money it's the
credit card companies money
okay in this particular situation the
government is you and the credit card
company is the american people
if the american people get back some of
their money that is not you waste that
is not the state wasting money
that is the state not spending money it
doesn't have
tax breaks are not
the government wasted it wasn't the
government's money it didn't come from
you
what in the world are you talking about
that's like saying if i steal your
wallet and it has a hundred dollars in
it and i give you 20 back
that somehow i have wasted that 20 it
wasn't my money in the first place i
can't steal your wallet give you your
money back and then be like oh yeah by
the way i just wasted money look how
generous i am
you know what'd be better is if i took
that money and invested it and then you
say what are you investing in like the
stock market nope i'm investing it in a
personal entitlement program called
alisana ferrari like that is what joe
biden is doing when he says it's an
investment an investment in what
in the growth of the economy no because
he himself is proclaiming that the
economy is going to grow at less than
two percent over the next 10 years
so what exactly is he quote-unquote
investing in and why is it that when
there's an investment typically the way
we refer to an investment is there is an
roi there's a return on the investment
if i invest in the stock market and i
lose 10 percent every single year that's
like that's a crappy investment
but joe biden thinks it's an investment
to blow money on random government
programs why because what is he
investing in he's not investing on
actual financial growth he's not
investing on actual financial return
he's not giving your money back to you
at any point he's not taking your money
and investing it for you the way warren
buffett would he's taking your money
he's blowing it on what he's investing
in is democratic voters
that is the plan the plan is when he
says it's a once-in-a-lifetime
investment he means i'm going to invest
in a bunch of people to vote for me i'm
going to bribe them to vote for me and
for my party until the end of time by
giving them things i'm going to enshrine
in american life more and more
government spending and more and more
government dependency so that you will
keep voting for a larger and larger
government bloat program that reorients
the united states away from free markets
and toward top-down controlled markets
in order to pay for all of this garbage
like that is what joe biden is investing
in he's not investing in growth he's not
investing in a stronger america he's
investing in dependency we all know this
nancy pelosi is doing the same thing by
the way she says
let's not talk about you know things
like money at a time like this money is
what what is money it's just a concept
you know some people use shells
some people some people have used bonds
we use happy dreams and and unicorn poop
this will be paid for so when some say
oh well what about inflation it will be
paid for and that's the the beauty of it
by having
those in our our economy and society who
have not paid their fair share paying
their fair share so again
the senate and the house those who are
not in full agreement with the
president's right let's see what our
value let's not talk about numbers
that's on dollars let's talk about
values
uh values values yes your value is that
you wish to centralize as much power in
the federal government as humanly
possible and to confiscate money not
just from people who are alive now but
future generations who have not yet been
born
and then use this to buy your own way
into the history books because history
treats very kindly activism government
activism but presidents who are
unbelievably crappy at their jobs get
treated as american heroes so long as
they blow out the spending if you're fdr
lbj can be unbelievably crappy at your
job and it does not matter you are
treated as an american hero as a
transformational figure in american life
if you're woodrow wilson until very
recently you were treated as a
transformational hero in american life
specifically because you strayed from
the constitutional limited government
vision of the founding fathers if you're
calvin coolidge you're very bad if
you're orangey harding you're very bad
you know you look at the 1920s in
american life i'm constantly struck by
this if you look at the growth rates in
the united states during the 1920s for
example they're really really really
high right there's a reason that the
1920s were called the roaring 20s then
you look at the 1930s and the 1930s
where they lost a decade in terms of
american growth the 1930s were a garbage
time for the american economy they were
horrific
not just the american economy the world
economy but the american economy
prolonged the great depression by
embracing top-down centralized
government policies courtesy of fdr but
who is considered a good president is it
the president of the 1920s who actually
presided over a booming american economy
is it warren g harding and calvin
coolidge who are considered the good
presidents no they're very bad if you
look at the historical rankings of those
presidents the historians ah those were
do-nothing presidents they didn't do
anything all they did was preside over
massive growth of american of american
economic power
you know as a great president fdr who
presided over america's complete
economic collapse for over a decade that
guy was great you know why because he
installed these programs that we like
ever so much
right the best american presidents
according to the historical crowd are
the presidents who blow out the spending
this is why in 20 years the presidents
who are going to be considered great by
the historians assuming that it's the
same group of people writing the history
books are gonna be people like obama and
bill clinton will have been forgotten
doesn't matter that bill clinton a
democrat presided over a rapidly growing
economy in the 1990s thanks to his
moderate economic policy which he
crafted in conjunction with the
republicans barack obama who had the
slowest economic recovery in modern
american history will be will be
considered a great president because he
enshrined big government spending and
joe biden knows this which is why he is
pushing this
and now there's one problem for joe
biden in all of this and this is he
can't get his own party together and the
reason he can't get his own party
together is because there are people
still like kirsten cinema and joe
manchin who are subject to voters who
are not crazy
right there's a bunch of senators who
are in deep blue states where the deep
blue states just feel like we can blow
out the federal budget no matter what
doesn't really matter
but the moderates and progressives are
still very highly divided over a series
of issues so democrats for example
according to the wall street journal are
divided on five key issues they're
divided on health care democrats are
wrestling with funding for and duration
of three central health care provisions
an extension of obamacare subsidies
medicare coverage for dental vision and
hearing and an effort to provide health
care coverage for some people in
republican-led states that haven't
expanded medicaid so the progressives
want to expand all of these things they
particularly want to expand medicare why
because bernie sanders has said for a
long time medicare for all
right he doesn't want you he doesn't
want you to personally purchase
supplemental insurance to medicare
instead of medicare being a baseline
insurance provided to you when you get
old instead medicare is supposed to be a
comprehensive insurance service that is
essentially nhs it's essentially the uk
nationalized healthcare service for old
people and then we'll gradually expand
that backwards in age right that is
bernie sanders pretty open plan he's
pretty obvious about this
pelosi says that all three of these
priorities will be in the final bill but
that could become increasingly
challenging if moderate democrats push
for a lower amount of overall spending
the healthcare puzzles becomes even more
complicated because kirsten cinema and
some centrist lawmakers in the house are
opposed to the democratic proposal to
quote-unquote lower prescription drug
costs by giving medicare the ability to
negotiate drug prices with
pharmaceutical companies
their plan could quote save as much as
500 billion over a decade money that
democrats are counting on to pay for all
of these big spending plans what they
want to do the democrats is they want to
use the federal government in order to
negotiate directly with drug companies
and by negotiating we mean crammed down
on drug companies particular drug prices
and then the quote unquote savings that
we earn from that we are going to then
use on medicare medicaid aca expansion
there's only one problem with this when
you cram down pricing on drug companies
what do you think the drug companies do
all they do is not provide more drugs
okay patents will be lost
these businesses will be offshored
people will incorporate their businesses
elsewhere there's a reason the vast
majority of medical patents on planet
earth happen in the united states
that drives the economy or it could be
like canada you can live off the fat of
the land trying to negotiate with these
drug companies separately and assume
americans are going to pay the freight
for that and americans pay the freight
by virtue of the higher drug prices but
what they get in response for that but
they get returned for that is that all
these drug companies work for the united
states
okay those are the choices there is no
third choice where they continue to
provide drugs at these at this
government negotiated artificially low
price and then also continue to develop
new drugs that is not the way this works
also the democrats are divided over
long-term home care and child care mr
biden's plan calls for 400 billion
dollars in funding for home health care
for the elderly and disabled west
virginia senator joe manchin has boxed
it spending that much as of other
centrists the house energy and commerce
committee drop a 190 billion dollar
expansion plan to help the elderly and
disabled stay in their homes senator bob
casey has his own 250 250 billion dollar
plans a lot of money progressives worry
an insufficiently funded plan won't be
able to achieve its objectives okay well
one of the reasons democrats are pushing
for this is because they are also traded
and they're also pushing for home health
care workers and child care workers to
be effectively unionized right they want
to treat all of those people as union
employees right this is their goal is
they don't want them to be able to be
treated as individual employees they
want them to be treated as unionized
employees
is a major issue in terms of right to
work
democrats are also divided on climate
the censor piece of the democrats plan
to address the climate crisis is the
clean electricity performance program
which would pay utilities that switch to
clean energy and penalize those that
don't because clean energy has been such
a boon in places like texas
okay it has not been that is me being
incredibly cynical and sarcastic because
these clean energy programs have
basically just made power
extraordinarily more expensive and less
reliable in most places around the
united states
utilities that increase their use of
clean energy by four percent every year
would get money from the feds those that
failed to do so would get hit were they
fine
but joe manchin comes from west virginia
which is a coal state so he's like nope
not interested in that
meanwhile on immigration democrats are
seeking a path forward after the senate
parliamentarian ruled they could not
include a pathway to citizenship for
millions of illegal immigrants
democrats are still trying to find a way
around all of this
one possibility they've considered is to
update an immigration law known as the
registry which would allow anyone
present in the country earlier than a
certain date to become a legal permanent
resident so basically make daca
permanent
they're also divided on taxes
senior democrats on the senate finance
committee and house ways and means
committee have prepared a long menu of
options to pay for the spending along
with tax credits that will add to the
bill's overall cost progressives and
centrists are divided on a new corporate
tax tax rate anywhere between 21 percent
and 26.5 by the way we are now going to
have a corporate tax rate that is higher
than china's if the democrats get what
they want they want to raise the top
individual tax rate and they want to
include measures to raise taxes on
private equity managers capital gains
and super-sized roth iras used by the
quote-unquote ultra-wealthy
as opposed to everybody else capital
gains apparently no longer apply to
people who are not ultra-wealthy which
is weird because it turns out that a
huge percentage of americans own stocks
also the top-line cost is at issue so
democrats are divided over all of these
issues and joe biden has no coattails
joe biden has no ability to whip his own
caucus into shape
we'll get to that in just one moment the
reason he has no ability to put his own
caucus into shape is because he refused
to actually govern the way he campaigned
he was always a trojan horse
what he wanted to be as president is not
what the american people wanted him to
be as president he's feeling the pain of
that but it's not stopping him we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first the lockdowns of the last year and
a half have created this huge pent-up
demand in terms of employment there's
like 10 million open jobs in the united
states and not enough people to fill
them this means that if you're an
employer and you need to find the best
possible employee it's kind of hard
you're kind of searching for a needle in
the haystack this is why you need a zip
recruiter right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on
ziprecruiter they send your job to over
100 top job sites giving you access to
their network of millions of job seekers
zip recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and then proactively
presents them to you you can easily
review recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
that encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zipper cruise technology is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the very first
day right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that's zippercrew.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-zip recruiter
slash dailywire zippercareer is indeed
the smartest way to hire we'll get to
all the rest of the news in just a
moment we haven't even gotten to the
biden administration just continually i
mean openly lying about border patrol
it's insane first you deserve to wake up
to the facts this is why we started our
newest podcast morning wire which has
been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its recent release it's the
only daily news podcast that values your
time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending toward number
one so please subscribe start listening
now to morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five star review if you like what you
hear you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so joe biden continues to try and ram
this thing through but he does not have
any coattails so
joe manchin is saying there's no
timeline he's saying listen you guys
keep pushing the 3.5 trillion dollar
plan there's no reason for it there
really is no reason for it if you want
to do it do it later right now we should
be watching and waiting at the economy
but joe biden is trying to ram all this
through at once because he refuses to
put pressure on the so-called
progressive caucus
this is something playbook is reporting
and it's kind of shocking
again the reality is that joe biden is
basically not putting pressure right now
on the people who ought to be pressured
namely the progressive wing
according to politico moderate democrats
expected biden to start twisting house
progressives arms during their white
house meeting last week but we're told
by sources in the progressive camp and
another senior democratic aide that the
president has neither asked progressives
to drop their demand that the
reconciliation bill pass in tandem with
the bipartisan infrastructure bill nor
pressured them to accept a standalone
vote on bipartisan infrastructure bill
this week at least not yet this has
infuriated moderates
a moderate source that quote the
president needs to pick up the phone and
call people the person argued the white
house has been in listening mode for too
long needs to start banging heads to get
this vote over the finish line it's not
just moderates that are dismayed there
are a lot of mistakes happening here
said the senior democratic aide there's
no whip effort on the bipartisan
infrastructure bill yet everything is
hanging by a thread biden needs to be
more engaged
progressives for their part believe that
biden police are with them
one house progressive said quote no one
has made the case to progressives or
lobbied for them to change their
position and vote for it before the
billback better act in fact the white
house when we were there on wednesday
was very much in the same position there
was agreement that we need both bills
so what exactly is pelosi going to do if
schumer and the white house don't get a
reconciliation deal hatched out with
mansion or cinema by thursday
no clue
no idea so pelosi keeps saying she's
happy talking this thing she says we're
going to pass this bill this week
but she said she's also not going to
bring a bill to the floor that does not
have the votes
so either there will be a magic moment
in which democrats come together here or
joe biden's agenda is in serious serious
trouble as well it should be by the way
it is worth noting here that the biden
inability to get policy done here is
forcing the federal reserve to basically
come out of the closet as a political
actor which has been for a very very
long time the supposed independence of
the federal reserve is kind of a joke
and has been kind of a joke all the way
since the fdr administration
it's been an open secret that the
federal reserve is pretty clearly
manipulated by whoever is sitting in the
white house at the time and that is
obvious with regard to joe biden i mean
janet yellen went from being the federal
reserve head to the treasury secretary
with no gap none
so right now the federal reserve is
always is already making noises saying
well you know if we don't pass this if
we don't pass these bills if we don't
get this this debt ceiling lifted we're
going to have to take some really strong
measures like what what are you going to
do that you haven't been doing before
jerome powell says the options include
the fed buying treasury securities in
default on the open market and selling
treasury is owned by the fed to
counteract potentially severe strains in
financial markets right the idea would
be that in order to inject liquidity
into the market the federal reserve is
going to just start basically printing
money and then buying bonds in order so
more quantitative easing essentially wow
never seen that before you're gonna use
a tool that you've been using
extensively for the last 20 years like
wow i'm shocked
among the officials who said such steps
could not be ruled out were jerome
powell and janet yellen oh shocker
pal called the measures loathsome others
called them repugnant or beyond the pale
for two main reasons first it would
pierce the fed's institutional
preference to avoid directly financing
the government often referred to as its
independence from fiscal policy wow
yes yes that that that fabled fed
independence don't pierce that by god no
no stop it
second fed officials worry if such
contingency planning became public
elected officials might feel less
urgency to raise the debt limit
yes because the debt limit is a bunch of
garbage anyways we say the federal
reserve is in control anyway it's been
in control for quite a long time
okay so bottom line is
and that joe biden is having trouble
getting his caucus together he should be
having trouble getting his caucus
together and all the pressure right now
is on mansion and cinema cave a mansion
and cinema have some pretty strong
incentives not to cave so it'll be
fascinating to watch how all this plays
out this week if mansion and cinema cave
then both of them need to go and go
forth with obviously and by by the way
the barton bipartisan infrastructure
bill will die
because the basic deal here needs to be
that counter
active pressure needs to be brought
on people like mitt romney and susan
collins and all the people who signed on
to the bipartisan infrastructure bill
the rob portmans of the world if the
democrats decide to ram through both of
these at the same time
then republicans need to force the
democrats to shovel all that bipartisan
infrastructure garbage into
the broader budget plan let them pass a
4.6 trillion budget if they really want
to own it all together they can pass it
all as one giant reconciliation bill
otherwise those republicans need to push
back and by the way my understanding is
they will the reason that mansion and
cinema have been siding against this
giant budget bill is because
specifically they are they are
in favor of the bipartisan
infrastructure bill and they know that
one's more popular so they are siding
with one over the other
so if they cave republicans need to push
back by abandoning that bipartisan
infrastructure bill
okay meanwhile it is unbelievable how
lies that are told by the social justice
left just become quote unquote fact they
are laundered as fact through our fact
checking apparatus and through our media
and no one seems to care
so one of the things that we have been
following here pretty closely at the
daily wire is the new standards and
practices set up by facebook so facebook
admitted that for the past year they've
been suppressing conservative content
essentially which we've known because
we've seen our own traffic statistics
some of the metrics that they use in
order to determine what stuff to
suppress is quote unquote fact-checked
material and they say this openly now
that if something has been fact checked
even if what is fact checked is quote
unquote missing context they will just
downgrade the distribution of that
material now missing context is a
designation that fact checkers left-wing
fact-checkers frequently use in order to
ding conservative content that is not
untrue so we print a true story
and then politifact says missing context
by which they mean that what we said is
true they just don't like that what we
said is true and then facebook
downgrades our content and meanwhile the
fact checkers let complete lies just go
just utterly unquestioned in the
mainstream media
which again plays back into
the facebook metrics okay facebook gives
credit to quote-unquote widely trusted
sources well what makes a source widely
trusted what makes a source widely
trusted is that it isn't fact-checked
that's what makes a source widely
trusted so legacy media have basically
re-enshrined
their own monopoly on disseminate
dissemination of information via the big
social media companies like facebook
that's why they were pushing facebook so
hard right all these big companies the
new york times and the washington post
they have columnists who spend every
single day just pushing facebook to
restrict dissemination of information
whether it's the hunter biden story in
the lead-up to the election or whether
it is conservative coverage of the
border all that stuff has to be
suppressed
and the way that they do that is they
have these quote unquote non-partisan
fact checkers ding every conservative
outlet and let open lies by the
mainstream media go and just pretend
that these open lies by the mainstream
media do not exist right this is the
shtick and it is really really effective
because when you when you launder bad
news through the system it magically
becomes clean and when you launder
actual factual reporting from the right
through the system it becomes quote
unquote missing context okay perfect
example of this so over the past
week and a half
there's been this viral photo
is a photo that went viral of an agent a
border patrol agent
supposedly grabbing an illegal immigrant
and you can see his quote unquote whip
ugh ugh he's whipping the illegal
immigrants
because a haitian illegal immigrant
who's rushing across the border and
apparently into the interior of texas
you can see this border patrol agent
leaning over his horse right this is the
viral photo wow and from his hand the
border patrol agent you can see that
there is a rain that is dangling now the
media started reporting over and over
and over again that border patrol is
whipping haitians
and you remember maxine waters saying it
was worse than slavery
he had columnist coming out and saying
this was reminiscent of slave catching
patrols systemic racism and now is a lie
from the very beginning border patrol
agents do not have whips there is not a
single agency of the american government
that is armed with whips hey that is not
a thing
if border patrol agents have horses
those horses are controlled by long
reigns as anyone who has ever watched a
western understands
again not a horseman over here but even
i understand that you need reins in
order to control a horse
but because the border patrol agents had
rains and the rains were long the notion
was that these border patrol agents were
either using full-on whips to whip
people or they were using the reins in
order to whip people
okay
all of that
was a lie not a single part of that was
true so here was the still photo and
then it turns out as i said remember i
said that there somebody had video of
this because there are tons of reporters
at the border that turns out somebody
did have a video of this of this exact
incident with that picture here is what
exactly happened on the video on there
for if you can't
see so you can see there's border patrol
asian he's ordering people out of the
river
he's yelling at people he's trying to
turn his horse
right he takes the reins and he spins
the reins in order to turn the horse and
here is one of the haitian illegal
immigrants and there's there's one of
them and he's running up the hill he's
gone right he's making his move up the
hill the border patrol agent literally
leans over off his horse and grabs the
guy by the shirt
and that right there is the entire damn
it
that's the whole thing
what you just saw is the most
controversial policing procedure since
george floyd in america
i'm not kidding that that is
what it has been right
hey this is the single most taken and
most distributed photo about law
enforcement since the george floyd
scandal of a year ago
now in that particular case
george floyd died beneath the knee of a
police officer
whether or not you believe that it was
causative
okay in this particular case
an illegal immigrant was crossing a
river illegally tried to run into the
interior of texas a border patrol agent
leaned over his horse and grabbed his
shirt
that's it you saw the whole video
that's the whole thing
still is what went around that rocketed
around the world not just rocketed
around the world but became the topic of
every major media show
have any of these major sources been
fact checked on this
any
they've all had to go back and issue
corrections now
but that doesn't matter apparently
the new york times for example put out
this correction an earlier version of
this article overstated what is known
about the behavior of some border patrol
agents on horseback
while the agents waved their reins while
pushing migrants back into the rio
grande the times has not seen conclusive
evidence that migrants were struck with
the reins
okay it turns out that waving your reins
at your horse is what you do when you're
riding a horse so that's not a story
what's the story is when you smack
people with the reins but that didn't
actually happen
hey and and by the way the journalist
who took the photo
said uh no i never saw anybody whip
anybody
the photographer whose name was paul
ratchet was speaking with ktsm
he said he and his colleagues taking
photos that day never saw any of the
agents whipping the haitian migrants
they were moving
some of the haitian men started running
trying to go around the horses says
rachie
he says quote i didn't ever see them
whip anyone with the thing he was
swinging it i didn't see him actually
whip someone with it those definitely
can be misconstrued when you're looking
at the
picture okay but that did not stop the
democrats from ripping on border patrol
for over a week on this
here was joe biden ripping his own
border patrol agents by the way you know
what has stopped the border patrol
agents from having to do any of this a
wall
a wall here here is joe biden ripping
his own border patrol agents over a
complete hoax it is just not true over
myth-making
it was horrible what to see as you saw
to see people treat it like they did
horses really running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences there
will be consequences it's an
embarrassment but it's beyond an
embarrassment it's dangerous it's wrong
it sends the wrong message around the
world or sends the wrong message at home
it's simply not who we are
it's simply not who we are we know who
we are is a bunch of senile liars
apparently again this whole thing never
happened it never happened
according to the mainstream media the
hunter biden story was a russian
disinformation operation but our border
patrol agents were openly whipping
people
our fact-checking media by the way we'll
tell you and they spent a lot of time
doing this a couple of weeks ago but
afghan the taliban were not hanging
people from helicopters that wasn't a
person who was dead hanging off that
helicopter that video that you saw of
somebody hanging from a helicopter the
taliban would never do anything like
that and then a week later their stories
that the taliban are literally hanging
people from cranes in the center of
herat
but you know they're not going to get
fact-checked on that
but what what is absolute fact according
to the entire democratic administration
is what is clearly and overtly a lie it
is a lie that border patrol agents were
whipping people it is not true there is
not one iota of evidence that this ever
happened
and every member of the bible
administration parents this every single
member
kamala harris who's just
woking it up over at the white house
here she is saying the images of border
patrol evoked slavery
i was outraged by it
i it was horrible and um and and deeply
troubling there's been now an
investigation that is being conducted
which i fully support and there needs to
be consequence and accountability uh the
human being should not be treated that
way and as we all know it also evoked
images of some of the worst moments of
our history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery
what in the world is she talking about
these are people illegally trying to
enter the country
not people who are attempting to
evade the country they're trying to come
into the country these are people are
trying to cross the border and claim
asylum so they can live here
they're trying to get into the place
that the border patrol is trying to keep
them out of border wasn't trying to
recapture them and take them to a
plantation
like what in what in the hell is she
talking about and it's just a lie again
it's just a lie okay but they don't care
about the lie because the lie forwards
the notion that they are part of the
constant revolution
right this is this is the bigger point
the bigger point is that when it comes
to democrats democrats are interested
in the lie that they have to do two
things simultaneously which are
impossible okay on the one hand
government can cure all your problems
government can keep you safe from coven
government can pay all of your bills
government can protect you from all this
vicissitudes of life government is the
be-all end-all
on the other hand
the government is racist the government
is systemically evil the government is
discriminatory okay so these two things
can't go together right over the course
of the 20th century these two strains of
progressive thought were in complete
conflict
the authoritarian top down we can solve
everything progressive caucus and then
you had the authoritarian bottom up
progressive caucus which suggested the
entire system needed to be overthrown
the compromise come to during the obama
administration was perpetual revolution
from the top
right the notion was that if we take
over the powers of government we will be
almost outsiders in our own
administration we'll sit here ripping on
the structures of government until we
can use our power inside the government
to change the structures of government
so this is why you see the weird
spectacle of members at the top of the
white house ripping on the border patrol
agents are part of their own executive
branch
how can they do that
because this is part of the entire
strategy which is we are the perpetual
revolution and give us power we will
make we will remake the system from the
inside along the basis of racial equity
right this is barack obama's claim and
democrats have picked up on it
democrats for a long time said no no the
system is good you just need to put us
in charge and give the system more power
now democrats say the system is bad put
us in charge and give us more power
that is the goal here
alejandro marcus the dhs secretary doing
the exact same thing these are images of
systemic racism
in the midst of meeting these challenges
we
our entire nation saw horrifying images
that do not reflect who we are
who we aspire to be or the integrity and
values of our truly heroic personnel in
the department of homeland security the
investigation into what occurred has not
yet concluded
we know that those images painfully
conjured up the worst elements of our
nation's ongoing battle against systemic
racism
these people are a damned joke they're a
joke they've been a joke for years by
the way by going all the way back to
michael brown who's still perceived in
in large swaths of the progressive
community as some sort of secular saint
right michael brown attacked a police
officer before he was shot to death okay
this is the the
basic idea here again is that all that
matters is the narrative and the facts
are of complete non-importance they do
not matter to this administration they
don't matter in the slightest and by the
way you're not supposed to pay attention
to the fact that this administration
which said that it was not open borders
took ten to twelve thousand of those
illegal immigrants there were fifteen
thousand people under that bridge ten to
twelve thousand of them have been
released inside the united states didn't
even get coveted by the way i've noticed
we've got vaccine passports everywhere
and now we're mandating that healthcare
workers throughout the united states get
vaccinated or get fired we're telling
businesses with more than 100 employees
they must vaccinate or test their
employees once a week
but if you're an illegal immigrant come
on in no covet test for you here's
alejandra mayorka saying 10 to 12 000
illegal immigrants have been released
inside the united states
of the 17 400 that weren't deported back
or didn't return on their own to mexico
how many of them either
well first how many have been released
into the u.s uh they're released on
conditions and approximately i think
it's about 10 000 or so 12 000 have been
released yes and of the 5 000 that are
still in process we will uh make
determinations whether they will be uh
returned uh to uh haiti uh based on our
public health and public interest uh
authorities
so they um they deported like five
people
everybody else got it
every single other person was just
released into the interior of the united
states
yep but it's not open borders guys
they're not open borders i mean i know
that you're sitting there going to
yourself well didn't trump want to build
a wall and all yeah they oppose a wall
you see
why did you allow them in the country in
the first place why didn't you build
forgive me a wall or a fence to stop
them from walking in this flood of
people coming across the dam it looks
like a highway that allows them to cross
the rio grande it is this poll the
policy of this administration uh we do
not agree with the building of the wall
the law provides that individuals can
make a claim for humanitarian relief
that is actually one of our proudest
traditions oh one of our paris
traditions is people crossing the rio
grande illegally being housed under a
bridge and then being released into the
interior of the united states for the
show up again date
that's a it's a proud tradition in the
united states that that's good to know
but here's the thing guys it's not that
they hate the patrol it's not that they
hate the border patrol alejandra
mayorkas also says the border patrol can
count on them
if you're a border patrol agent why
wouldn't you just act like police
officers all over the united states have
been acting and be like you know what
done i'm gonna sit here i'm not doing
anything because the minute i do
something and a photographer takes
something i do out of context
my career is over i'm done so i may as
well just sit here you want these people
in the country anyway fine
fine we're just gonna not do our jobs
we're just gonna sit here and if you
want people to cross over done
i'm not gonna participate
here's alejandra mayor saying the border
patrol can count on them after every
major member of this administration from
the president of the vp to the secretary
of homeland security is out there lying
openly about members of border patrol
can the border patrol count on you and
president biden who has said the people
will pay uh to come to an a
determination based on the facts
and and not based on twitter outrage
they sure can and let me say uh
something about that jake because i've
worked very closely with the men and
women of u s customs and border
protection for many years many many
years and not they are heroic
they're heroic wait a second i thought
they they were members of the
systemically racist posse rounding up
black illegal immigrants they're heroic
they're
the same message that the democrats give
with regard to the police they're heroic
except if they do their jobs and then if
they do their jobs and we take pictures
of them doing their jobs then they're
racist heroes of the kkk
it's just a pathetic administration
no wonder their popularity is declining
radically as well it should be this is
an administration in very very serious
trouble if all they get to show for it
is just a giant bag of spending even
that is not going to be enough all right
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show today he discusses house
republicans voting to make women sign up
for the draft you can check that out
over right now at daily wire i'm bench
bureau this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
house democrats vote to legalize
abortion nationwide up until the moment
of birth house republicans vote to make
women sign up for the draft and the
biden administration admits that it has
released at least 10 000 illegal aliens
into the country just last week check it
out on the michael knowles show